all right guys
bang bang i've got wes here with me
thank you so much for doing this
hey uh glad to be here pomp um you know
big fan of the show and
uh you know excited to chat with you
today absolutely
so uh right off the bat everyone's gonna
hear that you don't talk like i talk
uh which is a compliment because uh you
ended up uh with a southern accent
uh so let's get right into your
background where are you from
and uh and how the hell do you end up uh
doing venture capital having lived in
new york for uh for a number of years
yeah well i like to joke i think i might
be the first grain and cattle farmer
turned venture capitalist uh grew up
a little town called glasgow kentucky we
thought you know going to pizza hut was
a was a fancy restaurant if that tells
you anything you know about 10
000 people here in my town um and
you know spent spent the last 20 years
in new york city i'm actually back in
nashville now which
we might touch on a little bit but yeah
you know uh
my way into venture capital so so again
started small town kentucky
uh very very winding road for me so i
thought
like my forefathers i'd probably end up
you know farming as well really all i
knew to be honest with you
uh went to the local college i went to
western kentucky i was actually the
first in my family to go to college that
was a big deal and
you know like the joke you know western
kentucky is the harvard of uh southern
kentucky
um you know so they were awfully proud
um you know
the the lens you know got widened just a
little bit i guess when i was in college
you know now i had a few people from
nashville and louisville you know which
were the big cities
um and uh you know from there i thought
you know i thought well maybe maybe
i shouldn't farm maybe there are some
other opportunities out there ended up
going to duke for law school
um and you know pop i think you're from
raleigh so obviously you know so that
neck of the woods but you know
the aperture widened even more at that
point you know started meeting folks
coming from new york and you know
all over the world actually and
uh you know really got excited about
what i could do and you know from there
ended up going and joining us skadnarps
a law firm up in new york city
uh practice m a law um you know there
for
for
about three years you know representing
a lot of private equity firms hedge
funds you know likes of carlisle apollo
and all those guys
uh and really you know got excited about
you know what they were doing and said
you know what maybe i don't want to be a
lawyer i actually want to be an investor
i want to
sort of get over that side of the table
um and
you know had the good fortune of joining
a middle market private equity firm
coming out of skadden called trimaran
uh you know from there we were you know
investing in businesses across
industries i got to sit on boards i got
to work with entrepreneurs
uh you know really fantastic experience
working with some really good people
and uh we also ended up spinning up a
hedge fund while i was there as well
with uh with the guys from trian nelson
pelts and
and those folks who got to you know
evaluate public companies and and you
know really sort of develop
a pretty unique toolkit you know from uh
you know the law to you know the private
equity and sort of the public markets
um but really what i would say pop is uh
you know having spent about a decade in
you know private equity and
in public equities really started to
notice some structural tailwinds and
you know to date myself a little bit
here that's going back to about 2010.
um you know on the pe side you know it
was just everything was coming through
you know an auction you really started
to see return compressions you know
sort of across that you know across that
asset class same thing on the publix
right you just fewer public companies
more and more money coming into hedge
funds
um you know the rise of the clients and
you know the computers and just really
hard to be a stock picker there as well
so i started thinking about where where
might there be some structural tailwinds
and you know where my
you know i sort of uh you know be best
served to spend the rest of my career
and so really it started as is more of a
you know a decision just thinking about
you know sort of asymmetry around
returns and where i could generate some
alpha and
really started thinking that that you
know early stage whether it be micro pe
or or sort of venture capital really
sort of afforded a lot of opportunity
um on the back of that uh i started
investing off my own balance sheet
back in 2010 sort of testing this
hypothesis and
um you know me and a couple guys uh that
ultimately you know sort of sort of
launched third prime which we'll get
into
um you know put just under a million
bucks in the in the little company
called jingle punks
um you know fast forward two years later
we sold it to william morris endeavor it
was a fantastic
you know sort of outcome from a
financial standpoint but
more importantly taught me a lot that
all right i love sort of you know
getting my hands dirty working with
these entrepreneurs sort of from day one
or sort of being that first check-in we
were on the board there we were
you know making a lot of decisions over
you know probably too many beers and
whatnot but it all worked out
um and from there said you know what
this is really what i want to do you
know i
going all the way back to you know
little kid as a farmer it's been a you
know winding road but you know now i
finally see
it this is it spent the next few years
while i still had the day job still
working you know trimaran
uh putting a track record together just
via spvs going into you know individual
companies
and uh you know on the back of that uh
you know quit the day job launched
third prime in 2016. uh now investing
out of our second fund we've got a 100
million
uh under management and um you know
really you know like i said we got the
office in
in new york i'm launching an office in
nashville which i'm very very excited
about that city and sort of what we can
do
from that standpoint and you know uh
really also
um focused on uh investing in health and
wealth which i think is
um you know sort of has grown from sort
of what i've seen
you know here in kentucky having been
back since you know almost you know what
is it seven eight months now through
covid and you know sort of disparities
that a lot of folks here are facing
versus what i saw in new york
yeah so first of all you've had this uh
really kind of winding road where you've
touched a lot of parts of
just company building in general and
kind of seen from different seats
from an application standpoint but one
of the things i really wanted to talk
about with you
is uh most people listen to this um and
somewhat of an over generalization but
most people are going to be living in
a major metro so they're going to be
living in new york san francisco maybe
la
austin et cetera those places uh are
great i live in new york right so have
uh have no complaints
in that bucket but uh they're very
different than what we'll call kind of
middle america right or kind of other
areas that are not those major metros
you have this unique experience of
kind of going back and forth and really
looking at some of the
the middle america opportunities maybe
let's just spend some time talking about
like what are the differences and kind
of give us a crash course for those of
us that live in the major metros
like what's going on in middle america
that may surprise us or we may not be
aware of
yeah um well yeah look i think it's a
great question i do feel very fortunate
to sort of be a bridge into both
communities
and they're very very different um you
know what what i would say
you know first is what's the same right
i mean you know people care about their
families they're trying to provide
um you know they're they're they're
focused on you know their communities
um what what you see that's so different
though is you know you're walking around
new york you know san francisco yeah you
might see somebody's a little bit
overweight every now and then but you
know
you come into the small town kentucky
here and it's just
uh you know frankly like you know
obesity is rampant
um you know opioid abuse right just sort
of ill health
is is pervasive um there is
what i would also say it's really
unfortunate and it's something that i'd
love to sort of
you know try to you know try to improve
is um you know there's just
a bit of lack of hope right and you know
i think
you know you might see that you know
with trump coming into the presidency
and people looking to sort of rebel and
hey what what's been going on just
hasn't worked for me
right hasn't worked for these folks in
the red states you know you see
um you know real economic stagnation you
you find just
you know empty factories you know just
just across the landscape
and um it's it's really sad
in a lot of respects right you know i
talk to people down here you know sort
of in kentucky and and really try to
sort of probe into you know how they
thinking about things and you know
you you hear that look it's just um yeah
i don't feel like the opportunity's
there anymore
right you know i tried to follow this
path you know i've tried to go
you know do what my you know dad did and
granddad did and whatnot and just it's
not leading to the same place
um and i think there's you know just
immense frustration around that
and and people that don't really know
where to turn right there there
certainly is
you know high unemployment down here and
then you know you you see sort of
automation you worry about you know how
that's impacting their jobs and
you know i think we could you know we
could dig into several things but it's
you know
when people say you know sort of world
of haves and half knots i mean it's it's
absolutely true and you just see it all
over the place
yeah it's really interesting uh my
parents both live um
in an area in kind of rural north
carolina right outside of a place called
roanoke rapids
uh north carolina which uh you know
paisley faces got three or four stop
lights in it
um but uh one of the things that is uh
is really interesting
um is uh when clint and i were down
there last time
uh we were driving kind of through the
main strip if you will
and this main strip uh all of a sudden
just hit us
every single food outlet was fast food
i mean there was there you couldn't eat
healthy there if you tried right
and unless you went to the grocery store
and you actually went home and you
cooked and all that kind of stuff
but i'm talking about everything from
arby's to chick-fil-a to you know all
the way on down
and um it's one of these things where uh
you got to ask yourself like take
obesity for example how much of that is
you're a product of your environment and
how much of that is
uh no actually it's a poverty problem
right
and an unemployment problem and
therefore there's not a lot of capital
and so the only food that
uh you're going to be able to buy is
kind of cheap fast you know kind of
qsr if you will type restaurants so any
thoughts in terms of maybe
um kind of cyclically how this is
playing out
is it a poverty issue is it an education
issue
is it a just people want to do what they
want to do and and so that's just kind
of the lifestyle they choose like like
help me unpack
why this is happening more so than just
like what's happening
yeah look i i think a few components to
that certainly education i think we
could do a better job of letting them
know
um you know how they should be eating
right you know that that probably starts
in the schools and you know in the
communities churches what not
but um you know i think expected that i
mean you know
minimum wage is seven and a quarter an
hour right and so if you get a job
you know most people are getting seven
you know 725 and you think about that
right like there's just not much you can
do you're not going to go buy organic
produce they can seven and a quarter an
hour you just can't
right and uh yeah you you go to
mcdonald's and you buy the value meal
right because that's really what you can
afford and so i i do think you know that
there there are several sort of
uh you know aspects to it um and then
also just the the girth of options as
you touched on even the grocery stores
though many of them the grocery stores
are going out and all you're doing is
shopping at a dollar general
right and there you know you grab a bag
of doritos or you know you get
you know some some you know sugary
cereal that's just kind of what what's
happening and so
i think it's a bit of a vicious cycle
there and you know i don't believe
there's there's a quick or easy fix but
it's something that like i said it's
just
you know it's just uh you know pervasive
and it's it's it's incredibly sad
yeah i actually speaking of dollar
general i forget where i read this
uh maybe it's a filing or their article
or something
uh but that's basically been their
strategy right is to go find uh kind of
the smaller communities where it's too
small for a walmart to go
uh but the dollar general is kind of the
perfect uh you know
compromise if you will for the community
and like you're saying you know
they don't even have kind of fresh food
deli or any of that it's all packaged
food and
kind of not you know overly healthy
stuff um
as you guys are investing like how do
you see uh let's let's
stick on kind of just the health issues
right how do you see the solutions
coming
together are these companies that are
being built by kind of tech
entrepreneurs and
the major metros and they're going to go
and kind of save middle america
or are these more kind of what i'll call
home-grown solutions where it's going to
take people who are not in the major
metrics who understand these problems
uh you know kind of very intimately and
can kind of build the solutions uh that
way
you know look i i think it's i think
it's both and you know
you go to you know our portfolio and
i'll take two examples so we we've got
you know a company called the new primal
that's based out of charleston
south carolina and hoping you know me
sort of telling this story but you know
jason burke the ceo over there
you know grew up incredibly you know
impoverished right and sort of saw all
these issues i know his parents had you
know
problems with you know with obesity and
health problems and that served
as is the catalyst for him to say you
know what like i'm gonna go try to
improve things
and so you know sort of the
he started in beef jerky because he
thought oh this is healthy i'm gonna go
out here and start eating beef jerky
little did he know that's just you know
it's a wolf in sheep's clothing full of
sugar
uh you know sort of full of things
they're just you know terrible for you
and so he started by you know sort of
cleaning up you know that that product
and you know fast forward to today the
business is really
you know really booming and he's doing
you know cooking sauces and salad
dressings and really just trying to
you know be out there with um uh you
know sort of a narrative around you know
how to sort of think about that
educational component how to go back to
the table how to eat with your family in
your communities right in
a healthy and approachable way and look
is it more expensive than some
alternatives of course but he's very
much trying to you know bring that cost
down
very sort of mindful that that you know
initial mission which was to try to sort
of address you know some of these
pervasive problems you know around
around health and
uh you know ingredient panels and
whatnot the second one is is somebody
that's coming from from a very different
standpoint
right um uh an investment that we're you
know recently made in a company called
28 health which is
you know two folks that uh you know uh
have have been
you know from from bain and you know the
gates foundation and sort of all this
stuff sort of saw it from a very
different angle
but uh you know have launched a produ a
product that's catering to underserved
women digital health telemedicine all
that stuff starting with birth control
and sort of just access to that
which which again i think people just
don't realize you know sort of sort of
how difficult it is for you know sort of
you know maybe a you know woman in one
of these communities to to go to a
doctor
to actually get birth control and they
don't want to have a child but they end
up having one and you know what that
cost the system and what that cost them
and sort of just the snowball effect of
that
so so i do i believe that the solution
is being provided from all sides and
it's just you know those folks that are
that are determined to do it
um and you know to the extent that we
can play a small role in that you know
be a
you know capital and then you know
trying to provide some insights is is
something we're super
super excited about yeah so talk to me a
little bit about the
the wealth side of this health and
wealth thesis right so obviously
um you know something that i i just go
back to over and over and over again is
the lack of financial education
uh should be a national emergency right
in terms of of our country
uh i don't think that many people see
this play out right if you kind of live
in a major metro you basically see
uh kind of the the most extreme ends of
the two americas
you know if you want to think of it that
way you see kind of the ultra wealthy
and then you see kind of the homeless
drug addict you know type uh
you know narrative or path in life uh
but that kind of middle class
uh is not as uh obvious uh coming on the
streets of new york or san francisco
in middle america uh it is the middle
class right
and and there is pretty pervasive and so
talk through a little bit just about the
financial education and kind of the
issues around wealth
and money yeah no it's it's a great
question
um so so you know one of the things that
i sort of you know take issue with
or say say take issue with it but anyway
you know you keep hearing now about this
k-shaped recovery right that
that you know the folks that own stocks
or are doing great the folks that don't
are really suffering when you look it's
you know i think the latest data so
about 85 percent of the stock market is
owned by you know 10 of households
right um and you know most of that is
sitting in new york and san francisco
and sort of where you and i are
interacting you know in the venture
ecosystem and whatnot but
you know sort of sitting here you know
in kentucky and in nashville you know
you really you know sort of see the
difference between what's happening in
the stock market versus what's happening
in the real economy
right and you know i think you know as
new york times was also talking you know
what was it last weekend about
you know sort of milton friedman and
that similar work around you know sort
of shareholders right and you know
business you know what they need to do
is just try to drive value for
shareholders
and that probably worked 50 years ago
but i think what we're seeing now is it
doesn't
right because it just this disconnect
right this income disparity
has grown so large that there's just got
to be a different solve for it and so i
think
whether it's business roundtable stuff
talking about stakeholder capitalism
whether it's us
thinking about investing in companies
that are you know sort of solving for
all stakeholders
that's a big part of it and you know pop
they go back to your question about you
know education
um yes i think we could be
we could be telling them more right like
hey here's how you should invest and you
know here here's you know sort of what
you should do to be responsible around
credit and whatnot
but they just don't have much to start
with right so so we've got to find
ways to try to put more into their
pocket you know i think um it's sort of
you know first principle um and then you
know clearly that that'll come with it
but
um yeah i i give a lot of thought to you
know sort of that widening gap and it
just
you know every time i sort of come home
i think it gets you know it gets greater
and greater
and and there's you know if you go to
third prime's website it says you know a
reckoning is coming
right and it was sort of about what we
were seeing and this was before
sort of you know trump was elected and
you see sort of people going to the
streets now and you know just this real
divide
but you know i almost think we need to
revise that website and say the
reckoning was here
right i really feel like it's on us and
if we don't do something about it
um you know and i'm not saying that i'm
smart enough to know all the answers but
i know something has to be done
right or we're moving to a really bad
place
i read a book um and i'm gonna screw up
the name
uh but hillbilly elegy i think is how
you pronounce it
um and it was eye-opening right and this
is coming from somebody who
grew up in north carolina you know
generally thought i understood some of
these issues but uh by no means lived in
a
you know 10 000 person town or smaller
and the book specifically if i remember
correctly talked about west virginia
right and kind of a lot of the the
opioid crisis and the poverty
and just this world that um
almost sounded like a third world
country right i mean it really was
not something that you would uh have um
believed could happen in america to some
degree and so
it sounds like this is much more
pervasive than just
you know the coal mines of west virginia
type thing this is actually happening
across states you know between these
major metros
and it feels like it's uh systemic in
the sense of
um there's so much reinforcement to this
right or whether it's the health the
wealth just this is not something where
we go in and we just give people some
money and they're okay
right and maybe talk a little bit about
like
how do you balance in your mind between
like we have to change a system versus
we can actually come up with
i'll call them band-aid solutions right
or kind of things that directly address
the acute problem like how do you
balance that and where do you think the
solution lies
yeah you know look i i think it's it's
not just
you know universal basic income or
putting you know sort of money in
somebody's pocket
right like that's yes that helps right
now that's that's that's a near-term fix
but
but what we've got to do is you know
people want to work right they take
pride in their work you know they come
home from a hard day and
they feel good about themselves right i
mean i'm sure you do and you know i do
as well so like they want to have that
purpose
and so i think that that you know really
we have to sort of get to the root of
the problem which is just again
how do we you know how do we sort of
create jobs how do we do things that you
know that make them feel like that
there's that purpose and you know
they come home and you know they're
setting a good example for their child
and
um you know for you know for you know
contributing to their communities so
that's you know that's something where
you know i read that book as well i
think jd vance has a very unique
perspective
um and uh you know i i don't know that
he's got the prescription either
right but he's you know from from what i
understand he's trying to get into
politics now
thinking about that so obviously he sees
that certainly as a way that you know he
can he can sort of enact change
um i think we've got to do it from the
public side and the private side you
know sort of working in you know working
in tandem and
um you know i'm very much a capitalist
but i i do think that that it's going to
take
you know folks the top you know sort of
sort of giving back more
you know the progressive tax system you
know we probably got to be you know even
more progressive about that
um somehow trying to sort of create this
balance right but but it's just you know
bringing back
jobs trying to create you know something
that that you know
uh allows these people to you know feel
like they really got a purpose that
that's
that's you know sort of the biggest
issue to me when people say hey we can
we can go out here and put money in
their mailbox but
it's just it's still gonna break right
because they they just don't have that
that sense of purpose and what they're
supposed to do with their life
yeah how much of this is um around
entrepreneurship
in these communities as well right so uh
it's kind of become
cool for uh for certain demographics of
people to move to san francisco or new
york or l.a and start a company and be a
founder and kind of do that type of
stuff
it may not be as cool if you're not
building a technology company for
example or you may not have the skills
to do that type of business
but there's obviously opportunity in
each one of these towns
is there kind of the same rise in
popularity of entrepreneurship
in kind of middle america or kind of how
do you see that
having evolved in light of what you see
in the silicon valley type
areas yeah um you know honestly despite
you know people being on twitter and and
you know reading tech crunch and you
know
your letter every day right you don't
find that sort of permeating
little towns like glasgow kentucky where
i am right and so
uh it's you know entrepreneurship for
the most part is you know starting
a plumbing company right or opening a
used car lot
or you know buying a subway franchise
right so
um they are certainly impacted you know
they're they're on tick tock they use
instagram and facebook and all this
stuff as well
but it's it's it's certainly not you
know uh sort of pervasive through this
ecosystem to start thinking about
technology you know they're not talking
about coding they're not talking about
you know the things that that you and i
are probably often sort of you know
encountering on a regular basis
um so so that you know again to bring us
back to the educational piece right you
know how
can we change you know curriculums in
schools you know maybe to reframe it to
sort of do some of these jobs that are
going to be more future proof
um you know i i think that's a big part
of it but again these disconnects that
i'm talking about right
sort of the you know what's happening on
the coast versus what's happening in the
middle
it's not just you know sort of the
obesity and the health problems it's you
know
again it's it's educational it's it's
sort of aspirational there's there's a
lot of aspects to it
and then from your guys investment
thesis is it purely technology or will
you guys go
and invest in some of these other
businesses that maybe don't have the
you know zero to a billion users as part
of the plan
yeah um so so obviously you know we we
are you know venture capital firm and
you know we've got limited partners and
we're trying to you know provide you
know the best return we can uh as
fiduciaries
um you know that so certainly you know
technology is pervasive across our
portfolio
um but you know as i said before we're
investing that company the new primal
right which is
you know started with beef jerky and now
it's moved into some other foods you
know
obviously more and more venture capital
firms are investing in you know sort of
consumer and products and whatnot these
days but
you know by and large it is technology
what i would say about us though
is you know we've spent about half our
capital um in sort of what what we call
secondary and sort of tertiary
geographies right so we've got
uh you know entrepreneurs we're working
with in places like greensboro north
carolina and you know richmond virginia
and huntsville alabama
right and you know very much see
increasing opportunities to sort of go
into some of these
you know these communities um and to try
to wave the flag and say hey look you
know we're here you know to support
um uh so so yeah you know we are i think
probably more flexible as you know have
more flexible mandate than many firms
um you know that said tech is is by and
large a big you know big component of
all we're doing
one of the things that i've always uh
struggled with right and
especially coming from a place like
raleigh north carolina is you know how
big can the businesses get there not
from an aspiration of the entrepreneur
not from a
um kind of competency standpoint or a uh
um value of an idea but really around uh
the talent it takes to build some of
these companies and and you know
if you're in a san francisco or new york
you just have access to a bigger pool of
talent right now there's more
competition for that talent but but
it definitely is bigger how do you guys
think through
you know being able to build a company
in a huntsville or
a greensboro north carolina uh from a
talent perspective
and is it something where remote work
becomes much more important because you
can kind of tap into a global workforce
uh or do you see no we can actually find
the right talent
uh necessary just there locally um
obviously remote work is helping right
because you don't necessarily have to be
sitting in that location but but
you know i you probably you you do bring
up a great point um
you know frankly there's just not the
level of talent that you need to build a
billion dollar business
in many of these places and that's why
you know we've
we've got the office you know our
headquarters has been in new york city
and we're going to have the second
headquarters in
in nashville right but we still feel
like it is crucial to have that
connection to new york to those talent
pools to that
you know sort of series a and b um you
know capital
um so so i i i think while improvements
are being made while zoom is is having
an impact while slack and all these
other things are having an impact
it's it's still not the the full solve
um
you know you're gonna need to have a
presence in some of these markets and
some of these cities
to extract you know some of that talent
that's just not existing in in some of
these
you know uh more nascent markets and so
talk a little bit about uh kind of the
funding environment in these towns right
so
um obviously it's well understood kind
of the
the metros but but in terms of uh
whether it's kentucky or nashville or
alabama or north carolina like what does
that funding
environment look like for these founders
yeah it's you know it's changing
um you know you see more and more firms
you know that are that are sort of
willing to invest in some of these
communities but
um you know by and large i think there's
still you know valuation arbitrage
um that uh you know i know steve case
and the guys that rise the rest
published something not so long ago that
sort of
suggested there's still a 30 discount
you know in some of these markets
relative to
you know the valley and so forth i'd say
that's fairly consistent with what we
see
um you know so not only the valuation
standpoint but sort of an out you know
sort of
you know what comes from that is is
there's just not there's not as much
competition
right so oftentimes you know you're
trying to do a deal in new york or san
francisco
good company's gonna have multiple term
sheets um you know you're in huntsville
you probably the only game in town right
you're probably the only one issuing a
term sheet or at least if you
you know if you aren't there's probably
not too many around the table um and you
need to answer
your questions as well sort of what's
happening if those if those vc firms
aren't there
the gap you know is often sort of you
know friends family some high net worth
individuals that might be doing some
things but they're not dedicated to it
right they're capital but not much else
and they can't really provide that
bridge
to that series a firm that's sitting in
new york or san francisco which we feel
like you know we've done a pretty decent
job of doing
yeah and one of the other aspects of um
these communities just
over the years i've seen is kind of the
rise of
what would all really call startup
communities right
and what i mean by that is everything
from accelerators to co-working spaces
and kind of down the line
these are things that uh usually are
somehow incentivized by the government
right because it's good for job creation
and things like that
uh but they tend to help an entrepreneur
you know have an easier path they
obviously can't build the company they
tend not to you know be kind of advice
driven in terms of sitting on boards or
anything like that but
they they provide everything from legal
services to physical location
you know to work out of et cetera i'm
imagine that that has had to have been
an important kind of
accelerant for a lot of this but maybe
you've got kind of a different
perspective just having spent much more
time looking at this like talk a little
bit about
some of those service providers and
other things that are helping
entrepreneurs get started
in the non-metro cities yeah no it's
it is great i think they've got
resources today that that they've never
had you know the quality of that varies
you know from from town to town city to
city um you know but but nonetheless i
think it shows the dedication that shows
an appreciation for the need
to try to be cultivating
entrepreneurship in these communities
um you know for bringing you know not
only the entrepreneurs together but you
know folks that might you know provide
some seed capital
um you know that like you said those
service providers so i i think that is
um you know sort of an early sign of
sort of what what's to come it is
you know attracting um you know more and
more talent you know we've been spending
a lot of time
uh you know in charleston south carolina
over the past few years and
it's it's been really interesting to
sort of see um sort of the quality of
the entrepreneurs that are that are now
coming out of that town the
the number of those entrepreneurs and i
give sort of a lot of credit to sort of
the local accelerators and some of the
local
sort of entrepreneurs and angel
investors there that are really
sort of engaged in that community and i
think um you know they're they're now
um you know you know the prototypes
are out there right so i think you know
if the city is not doing it the right
way i think there are places they can
look and sort of you know make sure they
got the right roadmap
yeah well hopefully there will be many
many more
i think we're moving to a world where it
doesn't necessarily matter where you sit
if you can build a great business you
can do it from anywhere
um talk a little bit before we move into
kind of the rapid fire to wrap
up uh just your investment thesis
is uh very unique and so what does that
look like in terms of opportunities of
what you guys are looking for
uh and then also how focused are you on
specific
uh verticals right versus just trying to
find great entrepreneurs who are
building
uh awesome companies yeah no um
you know look if if you went back to
sort of you know version one and third
prime
you know we were just you know frankly
trying to try to make money um
that's kind of how we got into it
looking for the best sort of you know
risk reward we could find
kind of bringing that hedge fund you
know mentality to it um
you know sort of you know fast forward
to you know to sort of where we are
today and as i mentioned before really
focused on health and wealth really
focused on
you know those entrepreneurs that you
know believe sort of doing good as good
business finding that mission alignment
um and look and i think that we're still
you know
returns are are you know sort of
objective number one we're not an impact
fund
right despite you know hoping to have
you know a positive you know sort of
influence on
what's happening with our capital but um
yeah i i think
uh you know so so we we do believe that
sort of investing in health and you know
that
kind of a large you know sort of range
there you know obviously you know sort
of
food companies health care companies
even things that more environmental
health we've got some investments you
know and sort of you know folks that are
looking to
reduce carbon emissions and you know
things things of that nature you know on
the well side
uh you know again you know fintech you
know sitting in new york we've done a
lot of those deals but
um you know really also trying to be
thoughtful around who's providing a
product or solution to sort of all
americans not just sort of those that
are sort of sitting along the coast i
think
we've got a bit of a competitive
advantage there again sort of given the
fact that i think i
understand and know both of these
communities um so so really that that's
where we sit today
um uh and you know i think this this new
you know sort of vantage point sitting
in nashville is gonna you know provide
us a lot of unique exposure there as
well
so i gotta ask why nashville
yeah well uh so so again you know health
and wealth right so you think new york
you think financial services you think
fintech you know nashville you think
healthcare
right and and not only that but um you
know i've got i've got a lot of friends
down there i'm familiar with that city
and it's pretty incredible
right you know if you come to nashville
a number of cranes um you know just just
the folks that you see moving in i mean
you know every time i talk to somebody
they'll tell me i'm i'm you know sort of
the fifth person they've spoken with
that week moving from new york right
there's a lot going on
um and and not to say that uh you know
that the ventures you know scene in
nashville is
um you know is lacking but i believe we
can you know we can have a you know a
real impact there especially outside of
healthcare we're obviously going to be
investing in healthcare but i think
you know sort of the fintech and then
you know there's there's a bit of a
marriage too i'm sure you've you've been
thinking about embedded fintech and sort
of how all that looks and you know just
just ways that all this stuff starts to
converge
right and sort of fintech moving into
health care we think there could be some
really unique opportunities there
um so so that that's the reason for
nashville
makes uh makes sense not not too uh too
bad on the food the beer or the country
music either right
yeah yeah yeah you know and they uh
they're partial my southern accent down
there so that's good
i love it uh before we wrap up uh two
questions then you could ask me one to
uh to end it uh first one is what is the
most important book that you've ever
read
uh you know it's uh it's a good one i
um i would say that it was probably
uh breath to air um i don't know if
you've read that one it's
about the uh you know the neurosurgeon
that unfortunately you know uh
got lung cancer and you know wrote just
an incredible
you know incredible book about sort of
that experience unfortunately passed
away
but you know for me it was it was really
sort of you know important in that
you know i think we often think about
you know all right we're all going to
pass away right but that sort of
something just sort of shook me with
that book and then you know
it reminds me to to be grateful about
sort of what i had to try to be present
to try to enjoy
you know sort of every day um you know
and just
you know kind of back to the point again
try to make an impact right so so if we
can sort of
give more to some of these communities
improve some of these communities you
know it's something i'd be awfully proud
of
yeah that's a fantastic book and uh for
those who are listening who think they
only enjoy business books i promise
you will uh you'll like that one uh
second question is a little bit more fun
aliens believer or non-believer
definitely a believer
right i uh yeah i think you know it's
it's a bit you know
human arrogance to think that that we
could be the only form of life out there
so i'm definitely a believer in aliens
no uh no alien encounters or sightings
uh down in uh down in kentucky not
not yet but i keep my eyes open man i'll
let you know if i see any
i'm uh i'm always uh surprised by uh
there's only two people ever who came on
the podcast and uh asked about aliens
and they uh
said no i don't believe in aliens but i
believe in ghosts and uh
those two people happen to be josh brown
from ritz holt
and uh jim cramer and i said
of course jim cramer believes in ghosts
and not aliens
all right you could ask me one question
to uh to finish up what you got for me
yeah man so so you know a lot of talk
about the demise of the coastal cities
and sort of the rise of
middle america given what we've talked
about here where are you coming out on
that
more things change the more they stay
the same i tend to uh i tend to think
that
um maybe there's a little bit more of an
equitable distribution
uh now just because some of the uh the
moats that the large cities had
uh get broken down um you know through
remote work and kind of
telecommunications and things like that
uh for me
you know when i look at a new york if uh
if new york doesn't come back to
uh kind of the vibrant city that it once
was
across all kinds of different verticals
uh then basically you're not living in
new york you're just living in an
overpriced apartment
right uh if uh if it comes back though
uh i tend to think that there will
always be a very large percentage of
people that want to live
um in an environment where uh there's
just the collision of people and ideas
and industries and kind of uh
have access to so much uh so close to
them
um and so i think what you know this
whole situation has really kind of
forced people to just ask themselves
like what do i want
now what what am i being forced to do
rex and i don't have to go to an office
what do i want um and i know a lot of
people who are changing jobs and you
know
moving and kind of doing all that and i
know a lot of people who are just
staying and saying look i was already
doing what i want to do
um so i think that obviously uh the
change
will get kind of all the headlines
because it's awesome to say you know
there's a line around the corner at the
u-haul uh rental
but at the same time you know there's
there's quite a few people who say hey
you know
i'm in it for the long haul so we'll
we'll see how it plays out but uh
i tend to think that uh you know a lot
of the short-term reactions might be a
little overblown and
really get the data on the long term to
see kind of what changes for real yeah
right all right listen wes this is
fantastic
uh you've got a very unique uh kind of
perspective just because you understand
a place
uh that actually majority of americans
live but uh people in kind of
the san francisco's in new york they
just don't really get insight into so
thank you so much for taking time to do
this
where can people find you on the
internet uh find out more about third
prime
or or anything you guys are doing yeah
yeah so uh you can find me on the
internet pretty easy to remember farmer
underscore vc um you know as i said i'll
i'll go with that one
um and then uh our website thirdprime.vc
you know
any entrepreneurs out there that are
looking to solve problems for
you know for middle americans and you
know uh sort of in that health and
wealth uh you know sector
you know would love to talk farmer
underscore vc
might be one of the best twitter handles
that have come on this podcast
absolutely man all right listen thank
you so much for doing this i think
people are really gonna enjoy it and uh
we will have to do this again in the
future
yeah man i appreciate you having me on